Jupiter ascending is not a bad film it's
merely a ridiculously flawed film I love
this movie flaws and all for me it's in
the same sphere as Chronicles of Riddick
a offbeat space opera that is a thing
that should not exist but it does and
the world is all the better for it in
fact it's not just in the same sphere as
Chronicles of Riddick I love it for many
of the same reasons aesthetically
they're similar building on the
tradition of dune with a universe that
is filled with a society that is ancient
and bloated and cracking at the seams
they both draw on art deco and baroque
as a visual shorthand for opulence and
corruption and age Titus has nude heroic
statues lining the docking bay of his
capital ship the Necromongers fly around
in an oversized Oscar statuette so I was
rewatching Jupiter ascending when this
notion came up in my Twitter feed is
Jupiter Jones an empowered character
it's an interesting question because it
requires us to turn the lens not merely
on the film itself but the underlying
assumption of what is it that makes a
character empowered an empowered
character is a character that has plot
agency often as a shorthand we'll look
at how a character moves through the
plot both literally and metaphorically
are they a character who goes places or
are they a character who is brought
places most of the time that works well
enough because a character who is varied
from scene to scene is usually a
character without a lot of will or
agency but that shorthand is I feel
insufficient in this case and so we need
to look instead at composure while
Jupiter is often very very often set on
the back foot by other characters
looking to manipulate her for their own
ends she has never made the fool by
these manipulations rather than being
pushed around by the plot the plot is
explicitly about Jupiter competing in an
environment where the main weapon is
information and she is fighting at a
disadvantage the fact that she's a quick
study and is able to often hold her
weight when the odds are stacked against
her is a running theme of the film that
injects her with an agency that is
otherwise bolide by the fact that she is
so often carried from place to place
while unconscious this is a nuanced
distinct
the difference between a character that
is lacking in plot agency and a
character that is deceived and
manipulated by other characters this in
my opinion leans towards the latter the
plot is mired in politics with power
players maneuvering against one another
trying to use Jupiter and other
characters as pawns in their corporate
schemes the main characters being
tricked deceived cheated betrayed these
are core elements of conflict in this
kind of story while she is being
constantly told where to go and what to
do she frequently challenges these
assertions and tries to exert her own
will she comes up with her own plans and
maneuvers and pushes for others to yield
to her instead when she does accept
things without question it's an
expression of trust building further on
the interpersonal conflicts at the core
of the story as a result when her agency
is subverted or denied it is usually at
the diegetic level a result of conflict
a result of other characters trying to
manipulate her rather than being a story
convenience for the writers and this is
why composure is the important element
as written and acted how does Jupiter
hold herself and how is she then framed
by the camera the music and the editing
despite the fact that Jupiter is so
often literally carried from place to
place the movie doesn't treat her as a
thing even as other characters do
Jupiter retains plot agency even as the
plot revolves around other characters
trying to subvert her personal agency
there's an organic conflict to it a
back-and-forth of Parry and riposte that
drives things forward
is she sometimes powerless are her plans
sometimes deeply flawed does she get
duped into making terrible choices well
of course it's a story and that's how
our stories work but even then in those
moments her decisions still drive the
plot because a character being empowered
is not about them getting their way it's
about them influencing where the story
goes so go in peace my children in the
name of like share and subscribe amen